[Music]
I've faced my death at 23 years old I
face my mortality
[Music]
I was this skinny young overly confident
wild young man
nobody's ever ready for any type of
crucible or test like that
[Music]
everything just went to 11 in about one
second
and I thought I was hit because some of
the shrapnel hit the back of my neck
[Music]
and then the fire just became
overwhelming
[Music]
I don't have a lot of memories I don't
know if it's just I'm repressing it and
I don't want to remember I just don't
remember it seemed like time kind of
slowed down I froze but the gunfire was
going at a different speed you don't
know how to explain that
[Music]
it's very fragmented and jagged in the
memory it jumps straight from one scene
to the next scene then on to the next
scene
I come up pages flipped over real quick
all of it's very bright but there's no
sound
I've got a very vivid memory of a woman
I can see it
her headscarf was blue like a like baby
blue she's covered in blood
she's screaming in crime
one of our guys had put down one of
their guys like right there by that
doorstep
there's no sound even though I know she
was screaming
the memory stops and then it jumps
straight to the next part where I had a
very very clear picture of myself
standing outside myself
I remember the black door swinging open
seeing the women and I'm yelling at him
I can still see one of the ladies faces
the traditional Arab woman she looked
like she would surprise somebody grandma
you know was holding a baby you know I
think about that memory all the time
they're unwilling participants in an
ambush we were too they just had no way
to fight back
[Music]
all my members are out centre I'm lost
and I'm still in the middle of it by the
same time you know everything just
fragmenting
I'm wondering if I would be ready to
remember everything
because that's a lot to ask
going down that road it's a lot harder
than actually being there at the moment
but um
maybe they've got the courage and the
wisdom to do it now
I just need to build up the muscles for
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you